it's not my pleasure to introduce dr.
Jared Cohen president of Carnegie Mellon
University
Thank You Randy and let me acknowledge
your wonderful leadership of the school
computer science in general but also the
leadership who provided that goddess
from a concept to the reality of these
fantastic buildings it was a great
achievement we're all grateful to you
for what you've done thank you
needs to say it's a good thing we chose
the largest venue on campus to hold this
event at which bill gates will be
speaking there were twelve hundred of
you in this room 200 tickets became
available at time zero in about time 23
hours later they were all gone as I
informed bill a reminded bill earlier
today at Carnegie Mellon he is truly a
rockstar and here you are to prove it
once again this is a very special
occasion course the day on which we
formally dedicate the gate center
computer science in the hillman center
for future generations future generation
technologies bill of course has had a
great deal to do with that but he'd be
the first to point out that many others
have as well as we look at the
distinguished legacy of the school
computer science and we just had a nice
taste of the highlights in that video
were where that this is a historic day
not just for the school computer science
but for all of Carnegie Mellon
University and I would add for all of
Pittsburgh in western Pennsylvania
because of the absolutely crucial role
that this school plays in this
university and the role that this
institution plays in this region and in
the world our collaborative spirit has
always been one of the university's
great strengths and Weavin daly's seen
over the years how the work of the
school computer science has contributed
through that collaborative way of doing
things break few advancements in many
disciplines in many fields many of them
were mentioned already like
computational biology computational
finance cosmology fields that one
doesn't think of necessarily when you
hear the words computer science but
that's typical of the way the school has
behaved and performed since its founding
and even before
at the same time in taking on these
difficult problems in related fields new
areas of impute science itself had been
opened up in the school has jumped in
this idea of connections which Randy
talked about which the video talks about
with the which the book talks about
became the guiding principle for what
has become truly striking two buildings
they literally connect the campus from
one entity to the other and the building
in doing the buildings in doing so
strengthen the collaboration and our
culture which are so important to this
university the center's literally sit at
a crossroads of the campus you may not
think of that now but you will in short
order providing connections in every
direction on the campus and as you heard
one of those connections is the pouch
bridge named in honor of our beloved
colleague as a fitting tribute to Randy
who was passionate about the need for
artists and technologists to work
together the pouch bridge extends
between the school computer science and
the pronounced Center for the Arts the
bridge is a perfect example of how the
gates in helmand centers symbolize the
collaborative interdisciplinary way we
do things at Carnegie Mellon better than
any other university but you know you
know well we would not be here today
celebrating our remarkable history and
certainly not looking forward to using
these outstanding new buildings if it
weren't for this superb support of the
bill and melinda gates foundation and
the Henry L Hillman foundation these
gifts from these two foundations are
part of a long and distinguished legacy
of philanthropy at Carnegie Mellon that
enabled our unprecedented rise to
prominence as one of the world's most
important universities I thank the Gates
Foundation and the Hillman foundation
I'd ask you to join me in doing so
there are many donors to this bill to
these buildings beyond the gates
foundation in the Hillman foundation I
just want to single out one more that's
the McCune Foundation which made a very
substantial gift but also did at a time
that was particularly important in terms
of encouraging and inspiring our alumni
to follow their lead and we're very very
grateful for that I also want to
acknowledge the significant support that
we received from Pennsylvania's governor
ed rendell who worked in conjunction
with Pittsburgh's mayor luke ravenstahl
to provide support for the new planetary
robotics laboratory located in the gate
center even though he's got a few things
on his mind this week we're very
grateful that the Mayor was able to join
us today mr. mayor would you rise so we
can
and sitting next to him his partner in
great things not what something you
thought I was going to say Allegheny
County's county executive dan onorato
dan would you rise
these two gentlemen more than most
people in offices like there's really
get it when it comes to the role of
Technology in economic development and
the importance of that to the future of
this region I thank them for their
ongoing support which has been terrific
Randy showed you a slide listing the
Turing Award winners who are came from
or still with the school computer
science notably herb Simon and Alan
you'll receive their Turing awards in
1975 as a significant year because it
was the same year which a young Harvard
student had his own revolutionary
thoughts about technology in its future
that student embarked on what he later
called quote a little extra project
writing software for the world's first
personal computers the little project of
course became Microsoft and the young
student was of course bill gates were
very delighted and proud that bill would
take his time to be here today it's
actually his second visit to Carnegie
Mellon this year the first one earlier
this year was to our campus in Doha
Qatar and now he's here in Pittsburgh of
course to help us dedicate these
wonderful buildings please join me in
welcoming back Bill Gates
you